The denominator has M₁ either + or - M₂. Well, it can't be minus.
Otherwise, if these masses were equal, you get 0 in the denominator. I don't like dividing by 0.
Next, let's talk about this box. Should that be a +  or -?
Well, if it was plus sign, this numerator would always be positive.
That would indicate it would always accelerate in this direction, no matter what.
But clearly, if this guy is huge and this mass is really tiny, it should accelerate the other way.
Since negative acceleration is possible, this better be a minus sign.
In fact, when will negative acceleration happen?
When this term is really huge. Or putting it another way, when this term is really huge.
That means, this box then will have a 1.
To figure out what goes in this box, let's imagine the limiting case for this mass is 0.
Well, if this mass is 0, we just have a block on an inclined plane.
And in the lesson I just gave you on inclined planes,
you saw the acceleration in that case should be g sin α.
Well, if we make this a 2, well the M₁'s are both 0.
M₂'s will cancel out, and with a = g sin α. It works. Very nice.
This sort of thinking is the one we do all the time in Physics,
and if you're able to get this right, it means you have a very strong physics intuition already.
If you weren't able to get it right on your first guess, that's no problem either.
This intuition takes a while to build. Don't worry, that's one of the things this class is for.